Le 23 avril 1671, le prince invite
à Chantilly son cousin le Roi Soleil
pour 3 jours de fête...
Comment va réagir celui qui condamne
à mort quiconque lui fait de l'ombre ?
- Il y a 2000 personnes...
C'est vraiment l'un des principaux événements
à  Chantilly, du vivant du Grand Condé.
C'est l'époque où les jardins
sont en grande partie terminés.
- Il va accueillir son cousin
et lui montrer son domaine,
mais en lui indiquant
que toute cette magnificence
est faite pour lui.
- Fin stratagème...
Le Grand Condé laisse le roi croire
qu'il a transformé Chantilly pour lui.
Le roi s'émerveille.
Le Grand Condé savoure.
- Vous imaginez l'effet
que ça a pu faire à Louis XIV ?
Quand il a été invité en pleine nuit,
ça marchait.
Il y allait le soir, ça marchait.
Le matin ça marchait !
L'effet devait être saisissant pour lui,
quand même...
- Grâce à tous ces jeux d'eau,
ces grandes réussites d'André Le Nôtre,
Chantilly dépasse Versailles définitivement.
- Le Grand Condé, probablement
en son for intérieur,
prend un peu comme une vengeance
face au roi.
Pourquoi pas ?...
- Les années passent,
les générations se succèdent à Chantilly,
mais la rivalité avec Versailles continue
même après la mort du Roi Soleil.
- Les travaux à Versailles
se sont arrêtés net à ce moment-là
et les ouvriers se trouvaient
sans grand chose à faire.
Et donc le prince de Condé a dit :
Écoutez, moi aussi j'ai un château.
Venez chez moi !
- Cette nouvelle main d'œuvre va changer
radicalement le visage de Chantilly.
à commencer par les façades
du Grand Château.
- On a changé les parties hautes,
il faut imaginer des sortes de grandes tours,
au sommet, on a placé des lanternons,
des toitures,
on a ouvert complètement les murs
par un très très grand nombre de fenêtres.
- Les modifications se poursuivent
à l'intérieur.
C'est le cas dans le petit château
devenu, entre-temps,
le lieu de vie
des princes de Chantilly.
- On va créer une grande galerie
comme la Galerie des Glaces.
Avec les mêmes dispositifs,
vous allez avoir des baies,
qui sont les baies de la Renaissance,
qui vont être agrandies, réaménagées.
De l'autre côté, on va obstruer les baies
pour y placer des miroirs,
de sorte que la lumière des baies
va pouvoir se refléter sur les miroirs
placés juste en face,
comme dans la galerie des glaces
de Versailles.
- Donc c'est un petit Versailles.
- Mais là où le savoir faire de ces ouvriers
versaillais va être mis à rude épreuve,
c'est dans la construction à Chantilly
d'un nouveau bâtiment
qui va battre tous les records !